okay so dwayne johnson's about to be a
billionaire just so everybody knows of
course he's already making 80 to 120
million dollars a year as an actor
highest paid actor in the world
but on top of that his terra mana is
preparing to sell 300 000 9 liter cases
and shipped nearly 400 000 cases
in its first year comparing johnson on
social media to george clooney randy
gerber and michael meldman sold their
their tequila brand to spirit
diagram diagonals at 175
000 cases a year reportedly four billion
dollars
their our entire terra mana team and
myself are quite pleased and humble that
the brand is experiencing
this incredible off the chart success he
told forbes but we also recognize
there's much more work to be done we're
building a
mana fuel legacy brand and i'm in for
the long call
so what do you think you know what here
was my first reaction
um copycat this is boring another
another
superstar a-list actor trying to gravy
train off
george clooney and randy gerber's
success then you peel back you know the
ryan
ryan reynolds did it right he he had the
gin he had aviation ginny sold that for
610 billion there really is some money
in this
spirits business but then i peel back
and and i see what the rock is selling
this tequila for
and he's still in a bottle between 29
and like 39 bucks
and casa migos is like if you can get it
on sale it's like 46.
it's expensive it's a lot of money so i
give him
all the credit in the world now i'm a
fan he flipped me i
my initial thought was man do i really
need another a-list star that thinks
he's a tequila distributor i mean i
found it boring
i found it cliche actually but man he's
killing it it also shows the power of
the rock because i haven't seen one
commercial for this company i haven't
heard one ad on the radio
so it's all his social media that's
driving this thing and it just shows the
power that whatever he touches
you know it's going to explode and it's
unbelievable that that thing is
self-referential
i've never even heard of it never even
heard of terra mana never heard of it
you know there's this one app called
instagram yeah it's crazy and if you're
on this instagram
there's this guy named dwayne derock
johnson
don't follow him and he has like 200
million people that follow you know
and he posts videos of people that buy
his tequila every day
and he posts like 10 of them and people
having it and celebrate you've never
heard of this before i haven't i haven't
so the rock is a big deal by the way
who's the rock he is this
good-looking actor who's got swagger at
the highest level
alpha yet you're a fan of the rock i
think he is
the kind of guy you root for you cheer
cheerful you bring up the rock quite
often you want to see this guy win
you do he listen you cannot teach
charisma and have it at the level this
guy's got do you think it was a bad move
that he came out and
you know did his whole anti-trump thing
no i don't think i think because he's
planning on running he just told you
which side of the aisle he's going to
run when he runs that's all he did
he's going to be a democrat what that
told you is when he runs he's going to
run as a democrat oh you think he's
going to run
do i think he's going to run wow okay
how old am i right now 42
42 how long of a bet you want to make
you want to make a ten thousand dollar
million dollar bed
a ten year million dollar bet i i'm not
betting
i just wanna know this guy's gonna run
in the next 10 or 20 years
and he's trying to take a note guys
circle back in 20 years
he'll be 42. well let me let me tell you
this listen
there are certain guys there's certain
things that you just see
he he's the kind of guy anything he
touches
is going to turn to gold anything he
touches turns to gold
that's the rock he went to wrestling
wrestling
he became the face and you know they
were trying to make him the bad guy and
he came out he says i'm not playing the
bad guy i'm only playing the good guy
the other night we're sitting here doing
the lego where is the lego by the way do
we put it apart
oh my god the lego did it break or no no
we have to show it but somehow we got to
show it about that i don't by the way
you can't carry it only kai can't carry
it okay
so we sat here you just got sat down sam
we sat here trying to
uh what do you call it uh break the
world record this is pretty easy
are we moving from the rock we're done
with no no no no no still on the right
so so we're trying to beat the world
record right on um
tom we were so close so so the war
record for this is by four scientists
out of germany yeah
they did in two hours 51 minutes and 47
seconds
okay how many piece legos seventy five
hundred pieces it's really it's the
biggest thing
you have as many people as you want yeah
no it's only four shout out to your
friend kathy
yes gosh goddess dudes that's right you
said it good but you know how long it
took us to do it
we didn't three hours we didn't do it oh
yeah three hours yeah yeah
yeah we didn't do it in three hours okay
check this out look at this bring it in
bring it in
get in go ahead kai where are we going
bring it in right here just put it right
here oh my thing hogs my dreams watch
out watch out buddy
okay this right here took us this is kai
ladies so again
this is kai ladies and gentlemen the
world record
is two hours 51 minutes and 47 seconds
jesus okay
this thing took us not four hours not
five hours
not six hours not seven hours i don't
believe you'd put more than a couple
hours into it well for me
i had i was in and i was in an hour
i it got to the point where we sat there
and said guys i mean at this point
people are going crazy adam's knocked
out right i'm i am so we watch a movie
and we watch man on fire you ever seen
man on fire have you seen man on fire
have you seen manafort eric you've seen
man of fire is it a romantic comedy it's
it's not a
romantic comedy so you haven't seen it
so man on fire
is with denzel washington i think it's
dakota fanning in it and a few other
people right
who's the bad guy in the movie who ends
up being the bad guy mark anthony
compromises his own daughter to get a
you know uh 10 million dollar check or
something like that right and i said
why would you even play that part right
why would you even say yes to that role
why would you do that right the rock
said i'm not playing the bad guy
i'm a good guy i'm a hero that's who i
am that's his identity
this is who i am he goes plays it does
movies crushes it in movies does all
this stuff that comes out with tequila
at the end of the day the only thing
that's going to be left for this guy is
one thing totally to be the president
that's what i agree because he takes
over he when he goes into something
he's not content being great he has to
be the best so there was nothing left
for him to
accomplish in wrestling nothing he was
the best and he couldn't top it and then
what more can he do in acting i mean
there is such a gap between him and
anything else
he's not going to own a studio he
doesn't want to be a producer he's
laying the groundwork for some sort of
run he has no
question about it why wouldn't he do it
though and i think he's doing it from
the heart
i think he really thinks that he could
do a good job does he have your vote tom
is he running officially i don't know i
don't know democrat thomas thank you
i'm going to keep everybody in suspense
by saying i'm not sure yet here here's
what i
just want to point out i just want the
audience to realize what just happened
pat started with the rock
shifted gears brought up the lego piece
brought up the star wars brought up man
on fire mark anthony and tied it
all together into why the rock would not
play the back that was masterful i i
want you to know that because i was like
where is he going with the star track
and star wars i have to give a shout out
how incredible you did what i'm just
saying 99 of this is
this part right here this one little
tiny part that was me it took me 15
hours to put this together we learned a
lot about you doing this lego oh good by
the way adam spend
one hour just color coordinating one of
the bags
one bag color coordinating hey by the
way i was the setup guy do you what do
you think he's gonna do with the xfl can
he actually turn that into a success
because he's involved he probably can i
think he could yeah
i don't know i think he could i think he
could can we reveal how long this this
thing took to no no
by the way the video is coming out here
soon and we're going i'm going to
probably give away five of these if uh
uh uh when the video comes out you have
to see the whole thing i don't want to
give the time
on how long it took us well just but it
took us a minute all i can say is that
we did not break the record no i did not
break the record i had to cancel all my
weekend plans
literally to build this so for the rest
of you that are watching this
do you think he will run and do you
think he will win